all right here we go hey we're both
white isn't that nice I said insurance
you're white hello reject nation my name
is Greg Alba I am now introducing you
all to the lovely Mariah Garcia that is
mor iah not ma RI a let's make that
clear okay boom introduction done and so
she has a YouTube channel pretty new and
she has this segment called taco about
it that is ta Co not T al Qaeda okay and
she invited me on her show we had this
really fun segment you guys can go watch
that video link in the description box
for you all
yeah she just asked me a bunch of
questions she interviewed me and we she
interviewed me for about 40 minutes she
only found about six minutes of it
interesting so she condensed it down
into here that's exactly why it happens
because I wanted people to be like
craving more and to have you come on
again Mariah you have a lot of
spanish-speaking races in your blood I'm
assuming based off your name yeah
because I am stereotyping here well
there's this new Disney Pixar movie
called Coco I think it has to do it like
Day of the Dead
inspirations yes you've seen a Pixar
movie right yes you've seen cars too
no I'm just guys one oh sorry it was
such a good one yeah that's the that's
the top of it that was it a lotta right
than at the top of the fish chain you
know what I think
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow so Mexico
[Laughter]
you my boy are meant to be a musician oh
cool
[Music]
what is crazy
[Music]
Cocco oh whoa Mariah you know you can
see the screen I am way off to the side
and you got all this dead space there so
what did you think of said trailer from
Pixar I thought that was the cutest
thing I've seen in such a long time
can you relate to any of it I feel like
that was based off my life I think I
heard that Rena kala was supposed to be
like she don't really have a character
and she's one of my favorite artists
she's gonna be an actual character in
this song yeah I've seen the some of my
movie yeah I know a thing or two that's
a good movie yeah yeah there's content
in there they love the animations I so
created I believe this is made by I
don't you know before you used to be
able to just say Hispanic but that
upsets people now yeah a really divided
cuz there is a difference yeah my
girlfriend corrects me on that all the
time because she's Hispanic she's not
Latino gotcha I'm both good for you this
movie makes people I believe the creator
of this is of one of them
spanish-speaking races and so I imagine
this wouldn't be a Mulan situation where
Mulan was perceived as rather offensive
in China well you learn something new
every day you hang out with Greg I don't
imagine this would be something though
that that is offensive I think it and
have anything you would honor and
highlight and bring the culture them
it's a bigger life actually yeah
especially with everyone trying to be so
correct with whatever they say and
insensitive to others I am and not aware
of things like that
I wouldn't think at least in the film in
the film industry especially this looks
beautiful I like a good kid story about
you know following your dreams
cleaning here and then question you have
oh good for you
and this is so you are KOCO hashtag Momo
right I feel like you're getting so much
culture and if I know I've grown up in
LA my entire life so I've been around
plenty of Mexican family specifically
there's so much personality so accurate
to what I've been
yeah it's adorable I love seeing the
authenticity of it brought to life with
this magical imagination of the
afterlife of what it's at Delos yeah
that's what I was going for yeah that
hasn't come up yet I don't thinks I'm
one of my friends just started building
her altar that hasn't come up yet
John what were we celebrating today and
Pixar doesn't do musicals really in a
sense I feel like they'll have musical
numbers maybe not where they're breaking
in a song and dance but I imagine the
original score that they have whatever
this kids playing is gonna be like sorry
did frozen right know that was Disney Oh
learned two things you hang out with
Greg Coco you're gonna see it I'm
applying this new rating system and I'm
gonna forget about the next time I
filmed yay or nay wafer it on DVD John I
came up with I know why isn't John just
[Laughter]
wearing white yeah
I'm definitely gonna see this I can't
wait I have something to do on
Thanksgiving now instead of not being
invited by my family to go to dinner
with them even though they live right
next door wow this is you're just
letting it out yeah why don't you just
have her friends giving oh I'm running
low on those two so I got this guy but
he has a family and his family doesn't
let me come to Thanksgiving
I'm gonna watch cocoa really yeah I'm
serious
the things you know right Garcia check
out her channel talk about it hey guys
subscribe to the real rejects which you
can also do is please click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons
don't work if you can do us all a solid
and follow right Garcia on her YouTube
channel
Mirai Garcia that would be great because
we did a video together she has his
interview with this other girl on there
she's a little bit better looking than
me I guess some was somewhat hundred
thousand followers or hundreds of
thousands something like that yeah on
Instagram I have 12 so go follow her
number and check out our video please
because I drove about an hour to get
there it was some delicious tacos we had
so worth it
and you know getting to hang out with
you and talk with you in the interview
yeah it was great they talked out about
it they talk about it